where's the person with the
gun where's the person with the
[Music]
gun
hello how are you I'm good how are you
they gave us a call of a female with a
handgun in their lap a handgun yeah oh
no so I'm here with waiting picking up
my son oh okay no i s to bother you oh
no problem I don't know that's I was
like wait a minute where you coming from
I see you walking up I was like that's
the police me
sneaky put that gun away put it
down get out the
car put your hands back what you mean
I'm like to carry a gun you're fine
you're fine you're fine put your hands
back what are they talking about you
have it concealed yes sir okay I do all
right this is just for safety okay we
not in arrest right now okay thank you
you right and yes and there no guns in
my clip anyway no ammo no okay where did
you have it I had it orang you can take
me where okay my shoes
off nobody can see
you on your yeah
oh I got it let me put your keys up here
too
yeah you have your ID and your conceal
permit yes what is what is the problem
apparently they saw your gun and they
thought you it's in the car I have it in
my car that's where I have it okay I'm
just telling you it's no big deal she
got mad because she she got mad because
I asked for my order that was the
problem I didn't do nothing all I said
was I'm still waiting on my number one
order because I asked for it now I'm
trying to go home she got mad it was on
some crazy I'm like what you talking
about so I I'm wait I'm still here
waiting okay F I got a gun from I'm
still waiting we don't know all that I
don't care that's the crazy part she can
she can say what she want to say that's
weird the I'm still here waiting on
my damn
order do you have your license in your
uh can you pull my shirt up
please you have your Li what was I being
stopped for what is the problem I just
told me no you did not sir no you didn't
she saw your gun okay and that you were
threatening her with I did not threaten
her with nothing sir at all I did not
threaten her with nothing that's what
we're here no I've been sitting in the
car why would I threaten someone and I'm
still sitting in my car waiting on my D
order that doesn't make any sense I
don't know she don't she's not making me
sense that's what we're here to figure
out she's weird pull this up please she
pointed another person and thought that
she was going to f what I did not
say that she's a damn
liar we going to watch the video no
she's not going to sit here and
lie on me like that no she's not going
to do that and I'm going to call my mom
right now cuz she that's weird as hell
get my um no I'm going to get my I'm
going to get my own phon thank you so
she's a he's a liar she's a I don't have
a
car are you serious yeah all right are
you serious I'm done to with
though can you car
up get he's stay with zero AR you
serious I did not do anything to her I
just I've been waiting on my order I'm
going to watch the video okay well
please watch the video please cuz that
doesn't make no sense sir I'm going to
watch the
video call right
now
that's crazy I don't have time for this
I really don't this lady is crazy as
heck I didn't do anything at all I'm
just waiting on my order just waiting
bro she's a liar you're mad at us when
we're just responding to a call yeah but
I didn't do anything that's why I'm
still waiting here that out and if
you're acting out then it makes it look
like you're the bad guy no I'm not doing
anything like a bad guy I just don't
like that she decid her lie you said you
had the concealed permit you said a
license you've avoided it three times
yes I didn't do anything yes I'm telling
you what we're here investigating you're
not listening to me it makes you look
like bad guy no I am listening to you I
just the thing about it is I don't like
the way she seeting here lying cuz I
didn't do anything I'm just sitting in
my car waiting on my food I also told
you we're going to watch a video yeah I
just heard that I just heard that
because at the end of day he's over here
acting like I did something wrong you
guys come like I I didn't do anything at
all for a person was G allegedly okay
well I didn't allegedly do anything I
didn't allegedly threaten anyone I did
nothing
Legend yes sir I do you're being accused
of it it's not you did do it she's
accusing you of it yes we're going to
watch a video to see if you did do it
I'm not saying you did it I'm saying
you're being accused of it
mhm we watch the video you didn't do it
cuffs come
off everybody goes away
home we want to thank Morgan and Morgan
for sponsoring this video now before you
say oh great another Law Firm ad first
of all how dare you speak that way of
Morgan and Morgan and second of all you
don't know what makes them special you
see Morgan and Morgan has completely
modernized the personal injury claim
process they make it super easy for you
you submit your claim you sign contracts
you upload documents you talk to your
whole legal Team all on your phone and
you can text your legal team throughout
your case as much as you want yeah I
said team they have 4,000 support staff
I can't even get anyone here to get me a
coffee a tea a soda and let me tell you
I get parched it's no longer the days of
back-to-back meeting and consultations
an attorney is going to review your case
with eight clicks on your phone that's
it now you might be saying oh that
sounds pretty expensive well here's the
kicker there's no upfront fee no you
only pay them if you win so it's no
wonder over three million people call
them every year if you're injured you
can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
lawandcrime or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone okay and
do you have a valid driver's license are
you allowed to drive yeah do you have
that with
you I can't believe this lady really
just St up here and do like what the
heck are you do I'm going to let you go
but I want you to stay standing right
here okay yeah go ahead just stay
standing right here yeah I'm not going
to go anywhere I don't I didn't do
anything why would I run anywhere I'm
still here waiting on my food running
I'm not saying running I'm saying stay
standing here crap I'm still waiting on
my dang
food
and that's your mom
mhm get the number I don't know what the
heck she decided to say that's I don't
that's
crazy like I said watch the video it
shows you not doing it it's this number
right here go
ahead when you handed it to me it
clicked
oh girl where right
now that don't make no
sense 82 tell type can you copy a
[Music]
px go 32 that's the person in the
drive-throughs
on stand by for just a second I'll tell
you what give me a second I need no I
want you over there you stay here man
right
there and what do you want them to tell
her tell her to call my phone because
I'm having a problem at McDonald's that
could possibly send me to jail yes do
you want to wait to see if you get
released first cuz if we watch the video
I'm not going I'm not going to jail cuz
I didn't do anything watch the video
then yeah I didn't do anything I didn't
do nothing at
all if you watch video and the and the
allegations are false you're not
listening to me listen to me please who
watch the video it didn't happen those
handcuffs come off you go home do you
understand stand over here please do you
understand what I'm
saying so if you're going to be released
if you're going to be released do you
still want to call your mom yes I got to
call her I need to call her okay that's
weird he a that's crazy I don't like
yeah I just want to make sure that you
don't call her and then get released and
then no I want to call her now cuz it's
it doesn't she that doesn't make me
think she's lying I didn't do nothing I
didn't pull no gun I don't her why would
I do that sir I go to school for
criminal justice I would never do that
that doesn't make any sense well people
do it of
course accused of course but I didn't do
that nothing show people get falsely
accused all the not
got done I'm so tired of that she's a
liar that's weird I didn't do anything
nothing you want to put her in the car y
okay for what this car he under arrest
for what what what did I
do what did I do can you tell me Assa
assault of
what can I get my phone mom please
assault for what what the heck I didn't
do no assault
oh they're saying I you watch the videos
so oh my God these people are crazy this
is do make any
sense you all right yeah I'm okay thank
you can I get um can you call my mom
please I need a phone please I call my
mom cuz my kids are at home with um I I
came back and she come and get your car
too yes if I can get her phone please I
don't know what the heck she's talking
about it doesn't make any sense like can
you call that number and have her mom
respond and pick up the call can I get
yeah just call the number I didn't okay
first name what's your first
name say it again quave y quave
yeah all right watch your
these
be that
[Applause]
door step up against the
counter step up against the
counter give me a
second
G keep went upstairs uh can you do a
search for
me did you come back before I come can
you let her know
yeah I'll be in here with
you may we got your person that can po
or sck
me
INF forward for
me need to get to your hands no I'm good
thank
you what's that
uh whenever they get the chance to
transport
you find out for me what's that
no all right can you take your jewelry
off and just
in can I use my I don't have any numbers
on yeah like I don't know nothing yeah
I'll uh I have it in my
truck
myone to be call okay I'll put you in
there I'll go grab your phone and I'll
let you back out is
[Music]
[Applause]
ridiculous
assault assault like how is that assault
I didn't oh you you telling somebody
that you're going to hurt them you got a
gun next to you I didn't tell her I was
going to hurt her oh that's what her D
say that's the call that we
got you know what get a lawyer I'm see
at the Court cuz she's a goddamn
liar I didn't do nothing to
her so shit's
ridiculous no bro she got me I
didn't say I didn't even do nothing all
I said was all she get my order right
then I have already I mean that it was
in my car anyways the
I don't care the what they
supposed to do can't charge me the gun
the is registered is licensed I'm
licensed for this
F well the problem is that you have it
open openly displayed in your vehicle it
has to be securely contained yeah but
and try I ain't say that I was going to
shoot her or even point it towards her
well that in and of itself is a second
to misser to have it open in your
vehicle I didn't assult her
ass
it still was
concealed it was sitting on your
passenger seat yeah but it was still
concealed in my car it's regularly
accessible that's not concealed how is
that regularly accessible for me to I
would have to Li it up the gun was in my
car it doesn't have any bullets in it it
doesn't no okay well it's still a
firearm regardless of it we but it's
still my firearm I can carry my fire
wherever I want to that's a free whever
I want to yeah but it has has nothing in
it it's a f that's the thing it doesn't
matter if it has bullets or not bullets
aren't regulated that more that
much
anyway uh can you take the earrings and
does that nose ring come
out yeah but it didn't have nothing in
the in the gun anyway
mhm cuz I have was was close to put up I
have went to make to go get something to
eat I going to put it up and then this
happen and I didn't do nothing to her
cuz it was just sitting in my car take
the bracelet off and I ain't even I
ain't threatening her I a said I going
to do anything to her I ain't even
pointed at
her so I'll just get a over it's okay
you know you can't do nothing about it
and I can't
either
I CU she not going to say I did anything
to her and here lying I didn't even do
nothing cuz if I did that I would not be
still sitting at McDonald's waiting on
my food I would have left doesn't make
no sense I'm still sitting here waiting
on my like okay Bo and then you got I'm
like what that's why I was surprised I'm
looking at like what he I didn't even do
nothing you don't have any other that
would not come out
that's uh can you step in
so
two